Tali Klitschko is the Ukrainian world champion in heavyweight boxing who
dominated the sport together with his brother Bladimir for years,
he retired from boxing and is now fighting the Corona virus as the mayor of
Kiev. So far, it looks like another knockout from Klitschko.
[inaudible]. Thank you so much for doing this interview in English.
It's uh, it's actually, for me,
my small countable will be speaking in Ukrainian, but, uh,
let's speak international language in English is fine.
These days, uh,
Kiev is slowly opening up again after a strict lockdown
and, uh, in a city that has, uh, almost 3 million,
uh, people, uh, you have approximately 70 persons that,
that died from Corona. Uh, what about now? Are you holding your breath?
Uh, the question, uh, I talked to many, my colleagues, mayor,
mayor of Gamba and prac, and as European city,
their reservation is much, uh, difficult. Uh, why?
Because we in, uh, January startings, astray,
strange rules, we closed, uh, preschools closed.
The schools closed the public transportation, uh, uh,
because, uh, we following the whole situation in Johann,
uh, actually sister city of, uh, our hometown.
We have, uh,
contact with expert from Johann and they give to us,
it wise what we have to doing from beginning.
And that was, that was, that was, uh,
that was early on that you had a contact with the VU Hong, right?
Your sister city. Yeah.
Yes, of course. Yes, of course the people, uh,
the expert told it's will be not a problem in,
uh, Justin China is, can be wall a wide problem.
And after that, we, uh, followings is strict rules.
This rules have huge, uh, economic impact.
Uh, and the nobody wants to do that, but it's right now,
the question from one side economy, from another side,
life of the people, life is much more important.
Not everybody, by the way, understands this rules.
They criticize me, uh, because, uh,
they not happy, uh, with, uh, this rules,
the cause the Creek or the garden schools, public transportation.
But after that, uh, mom's letter,
we see the terrible pictures from Italy.
Everybody understand how dangerous Yvette and,
uh, they stopped criticized. They, uh, starting to sink,
he bought his health, his life and nobody wants to die.
It's my opinion. We do it exactly in right time and vet,
why the numbers of sick people in our hometown most are high.
And, and, and do you, do you, do you fully trust the numbers?
Uh, I trust the numbers because with doesn't have a idea to hide
something. Uh,
and right now all a scientist in the waltz, uh,
working very hard to find medication,
to find the injection, a vaccine against this, uh,
the sick let's see, we, we have to,
when the time it's our main goal right now.
One of your most important fights has been the fight against corruption.
How do you think that will be affected by the economical setback that that
happens now?
Um, you know, what the we receive, we receive a stressor from,
uh, from Soviet times.
The system system is big and
flexible and effective corrupt,
and, uh, it's very important to change the system.
And it's not easy system.
Don't want to change that why and, uh,
October this year will be next election.
I take apart, uh, already third time in,
uh, I will be candid that for, for the next election,
because I want to continue this fight. And, uh,
I want to bring European standards of life to my country,
defend rights of the people, defend, uh,
people from, uh, economical,
economic impact and medical and bagged infection.
And a lot of challenges had a lot of challenges because in boxing you have
one opponent, uh, in my position right now,
we have thousands of them. And, uh, you have to be in great shape.
You have to have spirit, you have, uh,
you need vision and, uh, it's very important.
You have to wheel to win this, not easy fight.
You are a professional boxer, three times world champion boxer.
Um,
and I wonder fighting this invisible enemy as a virus is,
uh, can you still, um,
can you still use your experience as a boxer when you,
when you plan a strategy against the virus.
It's totally different. You know, what is, uh,
I use my personal experiences, uh, citizens of Ukraine,
exactly the same situation we have in 1986 is
Chernobyl explosion. Um, uh,
nobody see, nobody smelled that, uh,
but we have impact little bit later from,
from radiation and exactly the same. You,
you doesn't see the, the virus, uh, right now after the winter,
everybody wants to go into the street. Everybody wants to make a picnic and,
uh, spent time together with a friends,
but very important following the rules. And, uh,
I deliver as information, uh, to everyone.
Please be responsible.
Well, when you, when you mentioned the channel bill, uh, is it true that your,
your father was a part of the team that had to deal with gentlemen?
Yeah, from beginning,
my father was air force officer and from beginning from Phil's day,
he spent a lot of time in Chernobyl and,
uh, yeah, he's died from, um, uh,
um, uh, from Chernobyl, uh, impact a little bit later.
And is your, is your mother still alive?
Yeah, since God still alive.
I was thinking about her because she has two sons that are world champion
boxers, and I, I guess that she spent a lot of time worrying about her sons.
Uh, but now with the Corona, I think it's, it's you,
that should worry about her being in the risk group. Isn't it?
Yeah, it's true. It's true. Uh, she's a risk, uh, uh,
risk group and, uh, that's why we carry about,
uh, old people and, uh, use of course about relatives and, uh,
that why Beth, why I deliver the messages, please,
if you don't care about yourself, please,
you have to be responsible about people around you every day.
Are I repeat every day,
one very important message. You are personal,
personal responsible for you, family, for you,
relatives for you, friends, for you city,
and please carry about a syncable them.
Mr. Glasgow, uh, your brother loved the mirror. He says about you,
that you were born to fight. What does he mean by that?
It's good to ask my brother,
uh, the simple, uh, the simple rules in the life. You have to fight.
You have to fight for you while you have to fight for, for you,
uh, for you city, you have to fight for your country.
You have to fight for your vision is life is fight,
no fight, no wheel. I know that better than anyone,
but to be the heavyweight champion, the world much easy as to be,
um, the mayor of key of mayor, of capital of Ukraine. Because,
uh, in boxing, you are responsible for yourself. You along the rink,
you are responsible for your team. Uh,
right now I am responsible for almost 4 million people who live in, uh, in,
in the capital of Ukraine.
I know that when you were kids, so you could, uh, fight your brother for fun.
Can you still do that?
Uh, we, uh, starting to fight a fight for fun. It's always,
we received the injury. Uh,
I think it's signal from, from, from the girls, never do it,
never five, uh, brother Phil's point and second point.
We promise our mom, our mom never, never fight,
uh, against the shadows and death, why we keeping our promising.
That's wonderful. Uh,
I know Mike Tyson was very important for your career.
He was an early inspiration. Was there?
Yes, of course. It's Mike Tyson. Uh, I,
uh, uh, I remember a great story. Uh,
I was 14 years old and actually it was Soviet time in
1996. Uh,
actually period striker came and we have a chance to, uh, to see,
uh, the broadcasting from, from, from the West.
And first time era in my life,
I saw the professional fight it's was fight. Uh,
when Mike Tyson knocked his opponents out
and, uh,
getting a title as a youngest heavyweight
champion, his wall, I was so impressed with his fight. And, uh,
I sit together with my friends and, uh, I promised to my friend, uh,
friends in, uh, one day, uh,
to beat Mike Tyson to be heavyweight champion. Everybody is, of course,
everybody, everybody, um,
smiling make a joke because I was small
and skinny and to fight against the machine
against Mike dice. And nobody believed me.
But 15 years later as the status was mine, the same title,
what have Mike, Tyson's the same title? What have Mohammed,
the Lee or Lennox Lewis. And, uh,
I asked my friends, you remember this day,
you don't believe me. You kidding me, but I achieved.
I achieved my goal. And, uh, I, um, uh,
explain the story to kids in the schools to everyone sends a message is very
important to have a goal in life. It's very important to fight for your goals.
It's a, and my favorite, uh, saying,
uh, nothing is impossible.
Everything is possible if you want very much, if you work hard and,
uh, you definitely each achieve any goal, what you have in new life.
It's rumored that Mike Tyson is planning a comeback.
If he challenged you, would you accept?
Uh, I have, uh, you know what, uh, as professional boxer,
I fighting two, three times a year right now as mayor of Keef,
I fighting every day, but total different ring, uh,
fighting for the people for, uh,
for the good standards of life as this fight is
much more important for me. And, uh, uh,
sorry if I received this proposal, uh, uh,
I have, uh, what to do doing,
maybe my brother he's good is great shape,
but I'm okay. I tell to my brother,
maybe he's thinking about this idea. Thank you so much.
And thank you so much for taking your time. Please stay. Uh,
thank you so much bigger regards to also Eve coronavirus, uh,
uh, these rules, uh,
I don't know in ways this year and the end of this year, if you have a chance,
welcome to keep them, they will be happy to meet you and, uh.
Love to meet you anywhere, but the ring.
Okay. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.